Whitehaven on the coast of West Cumbria
the location of a bitter and
increasingly political row over the UK's
first deep Coal Mine in three decades
the proposed Woodhouse colliery would
sit here next to the town on an old
industrial site galey Stevens is just
one of the many campaigners opposing it
it's wrong
the people of Cumbria the people of
Whitehaven deserve better than to be
taken back into the past Whitehaven
should be making
solar panels and new ways of doing
things but instead they're trying to
sell the local people on the idea that
there's money and there are jobs around
coal
this is a rendering of what's planned
it's taken years of wrangling but now
the government has just a few weeks to
make a final decision on whether or not
to go ahead
local Mayor Mike Starkey can see only
Economic Opportunity the coal would be
for steel making he says a booming
industry I would welcome any Renewables
coming into this border whether you want
a nuclear reactor a solar panel a wind
turbine they all need substantial
amounts of Steel and the only way of
manufacturing that steel is you need
gold King Cole
mining has been in my blood since 1964.
Dave Craddock comes from a proud family
of minors for him digging again is about
preserving a precious cultural identity
and its Common Sense our own source of
energy is beneath our feet you produce
power from what you've got not from
somebody else transporting it here
it's not clear how much of the coal
would be for domestic use or export
either way the decision is looming
this mine represents a really thorny set
of problems facing government ministers
on the one hand they've got the leveling
up agenda which means small investment
in the north of the country and they
want to increase our energy Independence
but on the other the UK is supposed to
be a leader on climate change and it's
been pushing other countries to stop
using coal which is the dirtiest of all
fossil fuels
for this reason the government's own
climate change advisors have said that a
decision to open a new coal mine would
be unacceptable
but a looming recession amidst a global
energy crisis might change the
calculation in the uncertainty of this
political moment Anything is Possible
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in West
Cumbria